سأكون مراسل CNN الدولي الأول ، هل
سيتابع ريبلي
هذه القصة المتطورة لك من
تايبيه ، هل ما تعلمته
مؤخرًا أن عدد القتلى يكاد يكون من المؤكد
أن يرتفع في الساعات القادمة
لمجرد الحالة التي
كان الناس فيها عند وصولهم  في
المستشفيات يمكنك أن ترى من
الفيديو وبالطبع تم تصوير هذا الفيديو من
مسافة بعيدة لذا يمكنك فقط أن تتخيل أنه سيء
كما يبدو من بعيد كم كان مرعبًا
أن تكون في منتصف
كل ذلك بعد هذه المباراة التي كانت
مباراة مفعمة بالحيوية بين فريقين متنافسين
بدأ المشجعون القتال وهذا
يحدث في بعض الأحيان تحتاج الشرطة
إلى الاستعداد لكسر العنف الذي يمكن أن
يحدث بعد مباراة كرة قدم متنازع عليها للغاية
ولكن في هذه الحالة هناك
أسئلة حقيقية حول
استجابة الشرطة ولماذا  لقد احتاجوا إلى
إطلاق الغاز المسيل للدموع على هذه الحشود.
بوابة الخروج
هي المكان الذي كان المئات من الأشخاص
يحاولون الدفع باتجاهه دفعة واحدة
لتجنب الغاز المسيل للدموع ، حيث ورد أن بعض الأشخاص
ماتوا على الفور عدة عشرات على
الأقل اختنقوا أو تعرضوا للدهس ، لكن
كان هناك أشخاص آخرون
أصيبوا بجروح مروعة تكدسوا في السيارات
وسيارات الإسعاف و  تم نقلهم بسرعة إلى
مستشفيات المنطقة وتوفي الكثير منهم أثناء
وفاة الآخرين في المستشفى بعد وقت قصير من
وصولهم ، ولا يزال بعضهم يتلقون
العلاج في هذه الساعة ويقال
إنهم في حالة خطيرة للغاية ، لديك 180
شخصًا أو نحو ذلك مصابين ولكن مرة أخرى بعض من
هؤلاء الناس للأسف لم يتوقعوا
النجاة خلال الساعتين الماضيتين ،
دعا الرئيس الإندونيسي جوكو ويدودو إلى
إجراء تحقيق شامل في
تنفيذ مباريات كرة القدم
وكذلك الإجراءات الأمنية ،
تعهد الرئيس ويدودو بعدم السماح بمأساة إنسانية أخرى.
مثل هذا يحدث في المستقبل ،
هناك أيضًا أسئلة حول عدد
الأشخاص الذين تم تكديسهم في هذا الملعب في
مدينة ميلانو  في شرق جاوة إندونيسيا ،
إذا بحثت عنه عبر الإنترنت ، فستجد أن
سعة الاستاد تزيد عن
42000 شخص ، لكن وزير الأمن الإندونيسي
نشر على Instagram أنه
تم إصدار 42000 تذكرة أن الملعب
كان من المفترض أن يستوعب حوالي 38000
شخص فقط  فهل يمكن أن يكون مكتظًا
مصحوبًا بالعنف
مقترنًا بأسئلة حول
الشرطة والطريقة التي استجابوا بها كل ذلك
إضافة إلى ما تراه هنا كارثة حقيقية
في الواقع ثاني أكبر كارثة دموية في
الاستاد منذ أه تعرف
كرة القدم  بدأت المباريات تقام في
الملاعب الكبيرة ، وكان الأكثر
دموية في بيرو منذ ما يقرب من 60 عامًا. Layla
129 شخصًا على الأقل تخيلوا كل تلك
العائلات التي ذهب أحباؤها
لمشاهدة هذا الحدث الرياضي ولم
يعودوا إلى المنزل